les Occidentaux eux disent le contraire
oui
là où on peut créditer Poutine de disons
d'un relatif bon sens c'est vrai que le
sabotage puisque il s'agit de sabotage
de ces pipelines
fournit un certain avantage à l'Occident
pourquoi parce qu'évidemment on sait
très bien que l'effort de guerre russes
est payé par le les recettes du gaz et
d'autant que les prix ont augmenté donc
c'est vrai que la Russie peut puiser
dans ses ressources pour financer son
effort de guerre là où il y a quelque
chose qui cloche c'est que le terrorisme
en question s'il s'agit si on peut le
qualifier ses actes de la sorte
que sont-ils par rapport à une politique
de Poutine depuis l'an 2000 ou des
responsables des dissidents l'opposition
russe qu'on rappelle hinsov qu'on
rappelle Pali de covska
tous ces gens là qui ont été assassinés
qui se comportent en théorie en
terroriste pardon et là on voit bien
qu'il y a
une question de un moyen d'inverser la
preuve comme d'habitude si vous voulez
la falsification de l'histoire par
Poutine fonctionne comme une manière de
justifier son action mais une hypocrisie
puisqu'il n'est pas derrière il n'assume
pas son action il ne dit pas je veux
faire ça parce que j'estime que c'est
juste il dit c'est parce que l'Occident
agit de la sorte que je réponds de la
même manière bon on voit bien aussi que
l'allusion au nucléaire est une allusion
qui précisément prétend répondre à une
agression occidentale alors que de fait
l'agression et l'invasion elle est russe
il faut pas perdre de vue cela alors si
vous voulez le l'argument est
intéressant puisque il dit au fond que
si l'Occident n'agissait pas de la sorte
il n'aurait pas lui procédé à une
opération dite spéciale puisque c'est
c'est la dénomination pudique et
euphémistique de de la guerre et qu'il
n'y aurait pas procédé à cela si
l'Occident n'avait pas été aussi
virulent alors quand il parle
d'opération il parle aussi du pont de
Crimée
quand on est en pleine guerre
effectivement il y a des opérations de
ce type là je remarque simplement que le
bombardement les bombardements en cours
russe sur les villes
ukrainiennes détruisent des
infrastructures énergétiques et font des
victimes civiles à mon information sur
mon information le bombardement enfin
l'opération contre le pont de kerks a
fait trois morts ces trois morts de trop
on est bien d'accord mais ce n'est pas
comparable ça veut dire en gros que
Poutine dit que les leaders européens se
sont trompés dans beaucoup de choses et
que lui a raison forcément et qu'il
vient en aide au peuple aux Européens
oui alors là il y a quelque chose de
très spéciaux là aussi puisque
d'ordinaire Vladimir Poutine et ça
correspond à cette volonté de bâtir ce
qu'on appelle ce que ces idéologues
appellent l'Eurasie c'est-à-dire une
structure autoritaire qui irait de la de
la Russie vers l'ouest c'est-à-dire vers
l'Europe et de l'autre côté jusque
asiatique russe et bien là-dedans il y a
quelque chose de très surprenant quand
Vladimir Poutine parle de l'Europe et de
la nécessité de la mater en quelque
sorte il dit au fond c'est le siège de
la décadence ce sont ceux qui ne
défendent même pas leur valeur donc il
n'a que du mépris et là il essaie de
séduire l'Europe en disant vous vous
êtes fourvoyé vous vous êtes fourvoyé
pourquoi parce que justement vous n'avez
pas suivi la Russie or depuis 20 ans ce
que fait l'Europe c'est de comprendre ou
d'essayer de comprendre la Russie alors
les esprits faibles nous diront mais oui
on l'a pas assez fait on n'a pas
respecté la diversité culturelle de la
Russie il fallait au fond être encore
plus docile et aujourd'hui c'est même
esprits vous diront qu'il faut lâcher le
don de base au prix de la paix ça n'est
pas sérieux ça n'est pas sérieux vu la
barbarie les actes de barbarie commis
par les Russes et surtout ça veut dire
que l'Europe effectivement a commis une
erreur c'est que au lieu de diversifier
le plus possible à cause précisément de
la situation climatique c'est moyen
énergétique